where can you see the eiffel tower  monsan michelle and the arc de triomphe  all within a few steps of each other  france of course  well  miniature france  [Music]  located two hours outside of paris  miniature france is a theme park made in  the image of real friends but at one  thirtieth of the original size  [Music]  the park is 12 acres in size and  features 117 different monuments  miniature france was built by a team of  50 model makers and landscape architects  ensuring that each model is an exact  replica of its larger counterpart  make this hybrid city come to life there  are animated trains cars and planes that  move around the region  [Music]  and while you might not have time to see  all the real france has to offer in one  day you can make your way around this  park in one afternoon  although your photos might not be to  scale  [Music]  you